ce que vous l’a faites cette opération
oui bien sûr je la fais comme tous mes
collègues mais quand je vois ce genre
d'extrait je me dis que c'est pas tout à
fait une mode qui est vraiment en France
actuellement parce que en France on a
quand même une idée un peu différente de
la philosophie du corps d'une naturelle
de l'harmonie de l'idée c'est pas
l'érotisation du corps à tout prix et
donc en France une intervention qui
n'est pas extrêmement fréquente d'accord
alors par exemple c'est vrai que vous
l'avez fait Noémie vous avez fait un
bébé elle vous avez fait ce qu'elle a
fait là
oui c'est à peu près ça pourquoi vous
l'avez fait vous êtes déjà envie de
tenter le truc vous l'aviez vu vous êtes
vous dire la vérité en fait je l'ai fait
je venais de commencer dans la
télé-réalité et c'est vrai que moi je
vais j'ai eu beaucoup enfin quand je
suis rentré quand j'ai commencé j'ai eu
beaucoup de de mauvais commentaires sur
Twitter parce que je fais une taille 40
j'étais pas comme les autres télé et on
m'appelait on m'a appelé Petit Potam il
y a fort sa force on m'a demandé en
partenariat donc de faire un BBL à la
base pour venir la vérité je voulais
plus faire une juste une lipo mais quand
le chirurgie m'a proposé bah BBL il m'a
dit écoute ta silhouette elle sera mieux
et tout je me suis dit bon ok je vais le
faire c'était à la base c'était un petit
complexe mais plus au niveau du ventre
et parce que j'étais un peu plus vous a
dit ouais je vais le faire proposer le
bébé je me suis dit bon bah ça s'est
bien passé
pas du tout non qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé bah en fait au moment de la
lupusion moi j'avais des implants
mammaires mais bien avant et il a je
crois touché ma glande ma mère c'est ça
il a touché ma glande ma mère et en fait
le lendemain que je me suis réveillé
j'ai vu comme ça il avait doublé de
volume
je les ai appelés ils m'ont dit non
c'est normal pas gonflé bah ça après
c'est normal c'est c'est le poste au
pays et le lendemain en fait on sent il
était comme ça et le sang il était comme
ça donc
je les ai appelé en pleurs je leur ai
dit bah il y a un problème c'est pas
c'est pas normal que mon sang il soit
comme ça donc ils j'ai fait une
mammographie et de là le chirurgien m'a
dit je pense que tu as une tumeur au
sein on a doit y avoir des ganglions on
a vu dans la dans la mammographie en
fait que tu as des ganglions alors que
pas du tout c'était pas du tout ça parce
que mon sang était hyper dur et en fait
non c'était juste qu'en fait avec la je
sais pas avec la canule il avait touché
ma grande mère et du coup il y avait une
hémorragie dans ça alors bon ça c'était
dû à la liposuccion donc pas les
opérations mais après j'ai eu aussi un
problème avec surprise
bah quand je suis rentré enfin le
troisième jour donc je suis parti à
l'hôtel et je me suis retrouvé donc avec
je crois que c'était une piqûre d'eau
aussi qu'au début donc je la gratté
souvent je la gratté souvent et donc au
bout du 5e jour je devais partir et je
leur dis bah j'ai été piqué pendant
aussi que je crois je fais une allergie
ou quoi il y a une disent non mais c'est
rien faut juste pas que tu touches tes
fesses pendant un mois donc je rentre à
Paris et là je me retrouve avec une
grosse boule plein de cul qui qui s'est
ouverte et qui je pense que c'était une
infection au final donc j'ai appelé un
ami à moi qui était chirurgien il m'a
mis sous antibiotique et ça s'est
dégonflé mais ça m'a fait une j'ai un
petit creux sur la fesse en fait
d'accord alors
Thierry aboudram ça c'est ça c'est on
dit que c'est l'opération cette
opération qui a le plus haut taux de
mortalité vous allez me dire pourquoi
dans un instant et cette opération c'est
vrai que c'est ça peut être aussi des
galères douleurs post-opératoire pas
possible de s'asseoir pendant un mois
l'expression dit faut souffrir pour être
belle mais là c'est vraiment c'est plus
que souffrir regardez
le corps met plusieurs mois pour se
rétablir complètement
deux heures après la fin de l'opération
Viviana sorte déjà de la clinique elle
se plaint beaucoup je lui déjà donné le
médicament pour la douleur elle doit
manger quelque chose
j'ai mal et dans la voiture il faut
qu'elle soit à plat ventre
à partir de maintenant comment je monte
pour que la graisse injectée reste bien
en place Viviana ne pourra plus
s'asseoir pendant au moins quatre
semaines
voilà pendant quatre semaines elle
pourra pas s'asseoir mais comment elle
fait
pas du piano
c'est vraiment difficile c'est-à-dire
que non seulement il y a des il y a des
complications habituelles de la
chirurgie comme à descrim Madame il y a
toujours des risques d'infection il y a
des risques d'asymétrie il y a des
risques d'hématomes et il y a aussi des
risques vitaux on s'était dit que
le lipo feeling des fesses c'est pas un
soin du corps c'est une intervention
qu'il faut prendre avec beaucoup de
sérieux et il faut bien y réfléchir
avant de le faire ça demande de la
maturité ça demande de la réflexion
avant une intervention et il faut
sûrement pas le faire juste pour céder à
un caprice maintenant de quoi on meurt
dans un injection de graisse dans les
fesses essentiellement d'une embolie
graisseuse c'est à dire que si on
injecte de la graisse dans un gros
vaisseau dans le muscle et bien la
graisse peut aller dans la circulation
générale bouchez le poumon et on peut en
mourir d'ailleurs il faut savoir que
cette intervention est interdite en
Angleterre donc ça donne quand même le
niveau et quand je vous disais que tout
à l'heure en France c'est pas très
pratiqué parce qu'on est quand même très
au courant des risques et bah de
l'intérêt
relatifs
français
à l'étranger c'est ça aussi
malheureusement vous parlez en disant 25
personnes sont mortes en Floride à la
suite de l'intervention de bbl en cause
souvent des chirurgiens verrues qui
prennent beaucoup moins cher mais qui ne
respectent pas toutes les règles
regardez
en disant 25 patients de son mortes en
Floride à la suite d'une opération de
BBM Rania avait 33 ans et vivait au
Texas pour l'opération comme beaucoup
d'autres américaines elle choisit un
médecin basé à Miami opération BBL tout
compris dans une clinique qui propose
des prix 35 % moins cher que celle de
Viviana elle était en blouse d'hôpital
elle lui a montré la pièce où elle se
trouvait et ça n'avait pas l'air d'être
stérilisé ça ne ressemblait pas du tout
à un hôpital
mais au bout d'une heure chandragnat se
serait retrouvé en arrêt cardiaque le
médecin aurait la serré son foie pendant
la liposuccion
docteur Cyril évoquait la dangerosité
j'ai lu un mort pour 3000 interventions
ce qui a un taux incroyable j'ai vu ça
dans un revue scientifique je sais pas
si vous confirmez ma question elle est
simple pourquoi est-ce qu'on interdit
pas cette opération si dangereuse c'est
ce que je dis effectivement c'est c'est
une intervention il faut toujours
calculer le bénéfice risque et moi je
trouve que cette intervention elle est
extrêmement risquée les anglais sont pas
plus bêtes que nous et s'ils l'ont
interdit c'est que réellement le danger
existe bien sûr faites dans des
conditions strictes de chirurgie dans un
vrai bloc opératoire pas dans une
arrière cuisine avec un anesthésiste
réanimateur de qualité avec de quoi
assumer n'importe quel complication
c'est une intervention que l'on peut
faire qui est faite mais aucune
intervention n’est sans risque et donc
c'est là est particulièrement voilà
problématique Valérie
étonnant dans votre témoignage
mademoiselle c'est que vous veniez pour
autre chose et c'est le médecin c'est le
chirurgien lui-même qui vous propose
cette opération donc qui vous pousse à
faire cette intervention à vous n'y avez
pas changé non en fait moi je j'avais
déjà des fesses un peu mais il m'a dit
en fait tu seras beaucoup plus uniforme
et même en télé ça va mieux passer donc
au final pour vous dire la vérité c'est
vrai que c'est un peu stupide parce que
je suis en âge de réfléchir et j'aurais
dû y penser mais ça s'est fait vraiment
pour vous dire la vérité en une semaine
genre j'ai la demande de collaboration
peut-être deux jours après j'ai accepté
trois jours après j'étais en Tunisie ça
c'est hyper choquant moi je trouve que
cette opération elle va entre 10 et
12000 euros c'est ça entre 8 et 8000 et
12000 euros c'est bon après bon bien sûr
il y a tous les prix parce que c'est
vrai que cette intervention est longue
elle dure 3h quel comporte deux
températures mais vous voyez c'est
particulièrement intéressant ce qu'elle
dit c'est à dire que il n'y a pas de
délai de réflexion on a suggéré à la
patiente une modification c'est tout
l'inverse de ce qu'on peut espérer de la
chirurgie je veux dire la chirurgie
c'est une demande d'une patiente qui a
un problème spécifique nous en tant que
chirurgien notre but c'est d'essayer de
lui apporter une réponse à elle pas de
lui imposer notre notre vue de se poser
les bonnes questions pourquoi elle le
fait pour qui elle le fait c'est ça
quand va-t-elle le faire et quel est
l'avenir c'est à dire l'avenir c'est
est-ce que la mode d'aujourd'hui et la
mode de demain
ça change là
c'est les petites feuilles c'est ça qui
fait de la peine c'est qu'au final on se
rend compte que ces jeunes femmes
souvent elles le font pas pour elle moi
quand je vois l'extrait de cette jeune
femme qui dit j'ai fait ça et j'ai pris
10 000 abonnés c'est extrêmement en fait
qu'elle se soumettent à une communauté
de gens qu'elle ne connaissent même pas
à devenir une sorte d'objet sexuel parce
que tout ça évidemment hyper sexualisé
aujourd'hui elle veut l'être entre
guillemets par mois le terme elle va
être bonne en fait c'est ça le terme et
qu'elle se soumettent à ça et qu'elle
mette leur santé en danger alors que
comme vous le dites c'est irréversible
et que la mode elle peut très bien
changer parce que Kim Kardashian ça fait
quoi ça fait 10 ans que c'est la mode et
mettre sa santé en danger pour ça je
trouve ça extrêmement dangereux et la
téléréalité a une grosse responsabilité
je trouve parce que jeunes filles et la
téléréalité
très érotique comme ça il fallait avoir
des gros boules des grosses lèvres des
gros seins et tout et je trouve que
c'est vraiment des dangers publics parce
que c'est surtout des jeunes filles qui
vont faire ça pour rentrer dans des
moules et voilà et vous êtes très belle
comme ça sans rien
vous voulez dire un truc non je veux
dire un truc à Guillaume c'est que le
problème c'est que si elles veulent
plaire c'est à des hommes comme toi qui
aiment les meufs bonnes
quand les hommes demandent trop à ce que
à la perfection des femmes elles ont la
pression et elle se retrouve à faire des
conneries
ils ont toujours préféré les belles
femmes ça c'est ce qui a changé c'est
les réseaux sociaux c'est on veut être
non c'est les critères
il fait beaucoup le nombre de gens que
vous devez voir arriver peut-être enfin
avec justement en disant est-ce que je
peux être comme ça avec une photo
filtrée tout ça c'est ça qui a changé
Instagram Tik Tok c'est un drame surtout
aux jeunes une fausse idée de
l'apparence de la beauté de de la
séduction et c'est vraiment malheureux
ça n'existait pas il y a 20 ans est-ce
que justement vous m'avez les
raisonnable est-ce que il y aurait pas
une charte à faire puisque justement ça
évolue dans ce très mauvais sens et avec
des risques très très importants il y a
pas une il y aurait pas quelque chose
et vous dites non à cette opération vous
savez que le risque évidemment moi c'est
pas du commerce de la médecine mais bien
sûr on est en France on a une éthique
l'éthique c'est fondamental
on a des règles on et j'espère de tout
mon coeur que la plupart de mes
collègues s'y soumettent et avec plaisir
ils ont envoyé leur vie à ça être
médecin avant tout maintenant bien sûr
dans tous les métiers il y a des
quelques dérives je j'espère en France
moins qu'ailleurs parce que quand on va
ce genre d'émission c'est je crois qu'en
France on garde quand même l'idée de la
du chic et de l'élégance voilà qui a
même des hommes maintenant qui se font
injectés de la graisse dans les
abdominaux pour avoir les tablettes de
chocolat dans les épaules pour avoir des
gros épaules dans les pectoraux c'est
bien sûr et apparemment j'ai vu des
photos de de garçon qui qui rend qui
sont pas bien foutus ils ressortent du
bloc ils ont un corps de rêve comme dans
la téléréalité mais vraiment tracé les
pecs en réalité c'est c'est mou
c'est-à-dire
en fait c'est toujours le problème de la
photo de la vidéo de la réalité des
choses vraiment avoir des amas de
graisses sur les épaules et sur le
ventre c'est pas joli encore il y a les
gars qui font ça il y a des garçons
beaucoup donc bien sûr et de plus en
plus c'est la grande mode
parce qu'en réalité moi j'opère par
exemple dans un établissement où on est
25 chirurgien esthétique à Paris et ben
j'ai quasiment jamais vu et peut-être
jamais vu un de mes collègues faire ça
donc
ça veut dire que vous très honnêtement
quand vous voyez des patients par
exemple si vous aviez vu madame vous
auriez été capable de dire et donc de
renoncer à voilà 10000 12000 € de dire
non je ne perds pas vous n'avez pas
assez réfléchi c'est trop dangereux vous
refuser des gens vraiment je refuse
entre un patient sur trois et impatient
sur 4 c'est absolument énorme je refuse
pour différentes raisons d'abord parce
que quand je pense que ça va être moche
je dis non ça va être c'est impossible
de faire une opération dont on se dit
que ce sera moche après enfin moi je ne
sais pas possible j'essaie de dormir la
nuit des fois la demande est justifiée
mais je n'ai pas la solution technique
vous voilà et est-ce que j'aurais dit
non à Madame c'est-à-dire que j'ai fait
des BBM dans des cas très spécifiques à
des gens qui ont vraiment une fesse
pathologique extrêmement plate et je
pense que ces femmes là elles ont un
vrai complexe et que ça mérite une vraie
solution vraiment c'est des gens qui ont
été heureux mais informés réfléchi
prendre son temps ne rien imposer ne
rien même suggérer l'idée c'est
d'essayer de rendre les gens heureux pas
de pas de se faire plaisir ou
aujourd'hui
ouais quand même je regrette franchement
je disais je regrette parce que au final
j'ai pas réfléchi et je m'en vais un peu
plus à moi quand même parce que je suis
majeur je suis vacciné c'est quand même
une anesthésie générale et pour le coup
j'en ai eu deux vu que il y a eu un
problème et je regrette parce que
finalement c'était pas forcément pour
rentrer dans le moule de ressembler à
Kim Kardashian pas du tout moi c'était
vraiment bah le complexe du poids du
ventre mais au final j'aurais dû
réfléchir et me dire bon bah j'en avais
pas forcément besoin en plus pour vous
dire la vérité donc j'aurais dû
réfléchir et me dire bon bah ça sert à
rien de le faire juste pour ressembler à
toutes les autres vous avez des
séquelles aujourd'hui euh non pour le
coup non ça va aucune séquelle non bah
c'est bien c'est les c'est l'essentiel
c'est content du résultat est-ce que tu
es content du résultat à l'actuellement
après j'ai j'ai des enfin il y a des
comme je vous ai dit suite à l'infection
j'ai un petit je sais pas si vous avez
vu Luna elle avait des suites elle a son
infection qu'elle avait eu elle avait
des petites roues sur sur la fesse et
ben moi j'ai un un petit creux mais ça
se voit pas vraiment c'est moi qui fait
au pire
non mais ça ça s'arrange ça fait rien ça